what is going on ladies and gentlemen
welcome to another Jenga tutorial in
this tutorial what we're going to be
talking about is we're going to be
creating a contact page and the way that
we're going to do it is by passing
information from our Python file to our
HTML file using Jinja variables and some
ginger logic so the idea here is on our
home page we showed how you can make a
really basic home page and this
information here is all included via
HTML but we haven't actually talked
about how you could take information
from a Python file and pass that
information to your HTML and then
finally on to your user who's actually
viewing your website so that's we're
going to be talking about here and we're
going to be making this contact page so
so the home page really basic contact
will be a little more complex and blog
will be obviously much more dynamic so
let's go ahead and get started and in
this example we're actually going to
pretty much be hard coding the variables
that we're going to pass through but
later on you can envision how you might
connect with maybe my sequel pull some
information from the database and take
that information and pass it on to the
template let's get started so first of
all we're going to be building a contact
page so is the contact page should it be
its own app or should it just be part of
maybe the personal page well if it was
going to be like a contact page where
maybe you had like a contact form for
the user to fill out and all this kind
of stuff it probably should be its own
app in our case it's just going to have
some information like hey if you want to
contact me here to my email okay so in
that case really this just is part of
the personal app so the first thing that
we need to do is not start an app and
install it we need to first access the
the views probably used up high in the
URL sky so first let's move this aside
and let's open up we'll go into views
for now so we'll go my site it's not my
site well go into personal and then
views on its edit that
and right now we have a view for the
index index request basically and now
we're going to do is for a contact
request so in this case we're going to
define contact we still pass requests as
usual and then in here we're going to
return render and then we're going to
return
obviously the request because we have
two and then we're going to return it
personal and then slash and instead of
any of these other templates that exist
basic dot HTML so my thinking here with
having a basic page is a lot of times
with a website you're going to have a
page that returns mainly just some text
maybe an image but it's just a very very
simple page so something like a contact
page something like a technology page
something like an about me page okay or
about you know about us okay in this
case the whole websites about us but
these are just examples these pages are
very simple so why would you have a
specific HTML page for each of these
that's silly
so so we have a basic HTML page and what
this page is is just like all the others
only it takes parameters or a variable
that is the content so for example now
we're going to pass this dictionary so
as I've said render takes basically
three parameters first is request you
got to have it what you're going to
render which is the HTML file you really
got to have it and then finally an
optional dictionary so in the dictionary
we can store things so for example we
can store something under the name of
content so content is the key of the
dictionary if you're not familiar with
dictionaries I do have a Python basics
tutorial on dictionaries you can go to
Python program go to the dashboard
search for dictionaries and boom Python
dictionaries so content is the key the
dictionary or the value will be a list
and the list will just be um you know if
you would like to contact me please
email me
and then we'll just put the email HS
kinsley at gmail.com okay so there's
that and then that's everything so right
now we're just going to basically pass
one thing so in our basic HTML because
we're passing this we can reference
content and the value of content is um
the value in the dictionary of content
so it'll be a list of two strings okay
so we've got that the next thing that we
want to go ahead and do is create the
basic HTML so we're going to save views
leave views go into templates personal
we don't have a basic dot HTML so let's
go ahead and copy home call it basic and
edit that and in here again this file
will indeed extend hetero HTML it does
not need to include anything and we'll
leave that paragraph tag alone so this
file is as I said is going to just
display basic information from that
content key of the dictionary so that
content key is a list of strings that we
want to show so we know we it strings
and we know we need to iterate through
that list we can iterate with Jinja and
then obviously we can display the
strings with Jinja as a variable which
you haven't we haven't shown actual
variables I've shown you how to do it
though so here we'll actually do it so
what we're going to say is we know we're
getting content so what we can say is
starting with some logic we'll tab it
over just so it's nice and clean for C
in content so we're passing that
dictionary through so that dictionary
just comes to this HTML file and then we
can begin referencing it like this so
for seeing content um what we want to do
and maybe we wouldn't want to call it
content now that it's icy its it'll work
it's just conflicting sort of with this
but it's actually not going to conflict
with block content but anyway you may
want to call it something else but we'll
leave content for now it'll work fine so
in Jinja you start a for loop like this
but unlike python
the foot like hTML is blind to spacing
and whitespace so so you have to close
off for loops so n for the same is true
you can also have if statements you can
have you know if um I don't know if
you're looking for a baler variable you
could have something like this so like
we could cut this so if C equals hi okay
or something like this you can have that
and then later on you can reference C
and then you always have to end the
statement so this will be end if there's
also else and all this kind of stuff but
we'll get there maybe at some point so
for C in content what do we want to do
well we in this case we really just need
we just want to print it out so they
have it in paragraph form so we'll have
paragraph tags and then we just
reference C ok the variable C and that's
it that's all we need here so we'll
close it all off like that
save basic dot HTML and we're good there
so at this point are we ready to push
live nope we don't have anything that
leads us to the contact page right so we
still have to edit the URL spy file so
we're going to come over there to
personal URL spy well edit that and we
see we've got these URL patterns if it
starts and ends immediately it's the
index so then we're going to add a new
URL paste and this time that URL would
actually be it starts and then it is
contact slash instead of use dot index
it would be views contact in the
namespace for this one would be should
be contact so right that looks all good
right we've we've already done the main
URLs dot pi so we lead to this one and
if it's nothing it's or basically that
starts and ends it goes here and then if
it has contact in it or it starts with
contact and slash it is we want to
return contact and you could even you
know close off contact
here we'll just go with that for now so
we'll save that and now in theory we're
ready but as you'll see we're actually
going to wind up with a little bit of a
problem so we'll open back up our my
site we don't actually have to have to
change anything actually at this point
so we'll come over here to our font our
website let's refresh make sure
everything works and then we'll click on
contact and it turns out we get a 404
now a couple of things will happen first
of all we can look at the 404 error on
our website and we can see and this is
all going to be the case if the bug is
set to true okay which you can see here
when you push this website live you will
want to bug to be equal to false you'll
only want to debug when you're really
like developing you should never have
debug equals true on like a live
production website because it can cause
problems so in our error we can see what
Django attempted so Django attempted
basically tried to read the URL and ask
the question does this URL start and
begin with admin or does this you where
I'll start in an end so what is this
list from the list is coming from the
main URLs dot PI file so let's move this
along over and move this over and we can
come to that main my site and then URLs
dot PI here edit that look at that and
sure enough course that's what's
happening so what's actually happening
here
is it is only looking if this starting
URL either had it starts with admin / or
it starts and ends so contact slash is
not either of those so it never gets
asked or sent to personal dot URLs to
further see about any other URLs like
our contact slash also we can come over
to this error here and you can even see
that warnings your URL pattern caret
dollar sign uses and include with reg ex
ending with a dollar sign what this is
telling you is you've got a dollar sign
here yet you're including another URLs
file that would require there to not be
a dollar sign there and what Django is
telling you is
is literally remove the dollar sign to
avoid problems including URLs so we can
move this aside and literally follow its
direction remove that dollar sign hit
save
come back over to this your website now
you're in slash contact slash refresh
sure enough everything worked and if we
did slash contact slash let's do like
this here you'll see that that works
right and it will continue returning to
contact why is it doing that
because we never actually finished that
URL so for example we can come to my
site personal and then URLs PI and then
you could actually close off that so you
could say ok at this point dolla sign
save come back over here we just that
worked a second ago run it again
now it does not work and we can see okay
now what URLs did Django attempt it
attempted start admin start and then
start and finish for the index start
which is this is coming it's like this
first one right this let me make it
bigger this carrot is coming from that
original URLs PI so this is the first
regular expression it attempted that was
a success then it attempted this one
right start net failure and it did this
one start yep start contact slash dollar
sign as an end no failure okay so that's
how that how it's going through and so
you can always read these and kind of
see what Django at least attempted and
then you can start to kind of debug from
there and you can see exactly what order
did it attempt to do things so that's
pretty cool so anyways that's that and
as you might be able to guess what's
kind of neat about these regular
expressions is you can begin to make
some pretty crazy URL patterns that have
never been able to be done in the past
when like the URL path was actually
exactly the path on the server so you
could only have pads that were like
legitimate operating system pads
whereas with Django you can have some
pretty cool hacky looking pads
that are just neat to have and you can
have various symbols and stuff like that
that you just wouldn't have been able to
have in the past anyway so that's our
example of building our contact page
pretty simple just like the home page
but we actually learned how we can pass
past variables and even do a little bit
of Jinja logic with our for loop as an
example there and then using the content
as a variable to just you know put out
to the screen so there are some basics
and now as we continue on in the next
tutorial what we're going to be talking
about is the blog now the blog is really
where like if you think you've seen the
cool stuff about Django up to this point
you haven't seen nothing yet
so blog is going to show us the true
magic of Django because so far we really
haven't made use of models I haven't
shown you the admin the admin page I
suppose of administration and all that
which is actually really impressive for
Django maybe one of the best selling
points of it if you ask me and even the
models that pie
as you'll see anyway so that's what you
guys have to look forward to if you have
questions comments concerns whatever
feel free to leave them below otherwise
as always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support in the subscriptions and
until next time